and Danny did you ever getting the music
the Beatles music you wrote to the
living Beatles and then the widow's yes
we you have to obviously Sony control
the financial side of it but Apple which
is the the two surviving Beatles and
their widows and the two of the widows
control the aesthetic you know how it's
used so it's not so the music isn't
misused and it's incredibly expensive I
mean it's the most expensive item I've
know the second most expensive item I've
ever had in a film what was the first
Leonardo DiCaprio's failed they were
beautiful they were shot in the film and
they roll we got a lovely letter off
Ringo and off Olivia George's Widow very
beautiful letters back from them so I
you know they don't they don't need to
kind of like recommend the film yeah
they gave us the go-ahead to go with the
film because you grew up with their
music I mean you were a kid when they
were in the charts and stuff well I was
like I remember being 7 years old and I
have a twin sister and we used to play
upstairs in bed
pretending to she was in love with Paul
McCartney so she would play Paul and I
would therefore play John and we had a
younger sister Bernadette who was four
and she would play George your Ringo the
others but meanwhile our parents were
play and the reason we were playing it
is cuz downstairs her parents were
playing the original 7-inch singles yeah
might love me do and please please me
and you always think of your parents as
old don't you yeah obviously when I've
been doing this film I realized they
were young there they were dancing
downstairs to the original Beatles music
you
[Music]